imagine if you were to have an
intelligent sheet that can sell fold
into any form it wants any time and
that's what I've been working on and I
call this robotic origami
robogami 10 years later with my group of
ninja origami robotic researchers we
have a new generation of robogamies this
one actually navigates through different
terrains autonomously so when it's a dry
and flat land it crawls and if you meet
sudden a rough terrain it starts rolling
it's the same robot but depending on
which terrain it meets it activates
different sequence of actuators that's
on board and once it meets an obstacle
it jumps over it it does this by storing
an energy in its leachable legs and
releasing it and catapulting like a
slingshot for robogummies there's no one
fixed shape nor task they can transform
into anything anywhere anytime